شكرا جزيلا لكم الزملاء لهذا اليوم
عملنا المشترك بسبب الخاص بك
للمشاركة في هذا العمل ، أعطي الكلمة
رئيس اللجنة
لدي نسخة طبق الأصل صغيرة لأن
رئيس أذربيجان
المستخدمة في كلامي
هزيمة التي
السنوات الأخيرة بمثابة عنوان
لتقديم مطالبات إقليمية
ضد أرمينيا أريد أن أقول ذلك
يتم استخدامه في الداخل
بيان ثلاثي في ​​9 نوفمبر 2020
العام أريد أن أؤكد ذلك في هذا
إفادة
ممر واحد فقط مذكور وذاك
الممر اللاتيني الذي كان من المفترض أن
يكون
تحت سيطرة قوات حفظ السلام الروسية ولكن
للأسف
تم حظره بشكل غير قانوني بواسطة
أذربيجان
من ناحية أخرى التي تمر
أراضي جمهورية أرمينيا ، نحن
استدعاء إذا كانت المؤسسة و
المجمعات الصناعية مع منطقتنا
شركاء أطلب منك فقط السماح لهم
اجبوا وقلوا ان اذربيجان
لا يوجد ممر مسدود ما
لمس طريق لاتشين خانكا ، ثم هي
فتحت على الحدود بين أرمينيا
التي انتم اذربيجان
التعرف على مثبتة
نقطة تفتيش حدودية ب
وفقا لجميع الدولية
هذا الحاجز الحدودي
تقع على بعد 20 مترا من البريد
وحدة حفظ السلام الروسية و
اليوم من خلال هذا
سكان الحاجز الحدودي
العرق الأذربيجاني الأرمني
الذين يعيشون بحرية في كاراباخ
التحرك نحو أرمينيا لا
لا توجد عقبات للأسف لدينا الكثير
التناقضات تصل إلى المسلحين
سنكون قادرين الآن كما نحن
متفق عليه في شكل ثلاثي على
الجميع هادئ بطريقة عملية
أتحدث وأتمنى أن أصل إلى البعض
الاتفاقات التي ستقود الطريق
مثل هذا التطور البناء للوضع
ليس فقط بين أرمينيا وأذربيجان
في المنطقة ككل